what's the role of sexual violence in
human evolution
because you mentioned taking
neanderthal females you've also
mentioned that some of these rules are
defined by the
uh by the male side of the society
what's the role of sexual violence in
this story
i think you've got to distinguish
between groups and within groups
and um
you know i think where the world has
been slowly waking up over the last
several decades uh to the fact that
sexual violence is uh routine in uh war
and that to me says that
um
it's just another example of power
corrupts because uh you know when
uh frustrated
uh scared
uh elated
soldiers come upon
females in a group
that has been essential dehumanization
of
then
they get carried away by opportunity
it is not always possible to argue that
this is adaptive
uh nowadays
because you know you get lots and lots
of stories of um
women being
abused to the point of of being killed
uh you know she'll be gang raped and and
then killed there's lots of of uh
terrible
cases of that reported from all sorts of
different wars
but you can see that that could build on
a
um a pattern that would have been uh
adaptive if happening in under
sort of much less extreme circumstances
uh
you know the the war is is very extreme
nowadays in the sense that you get
battles in which people are sent by a
military hierarchy into a war situation
in which they do not feel what hunters
and gatherers would typically have felt
which would have been that if we attack
we have an excellent chance of getting
away with it
nowadays uh you know you're sent in
across the somme or whatever it is and
and there's a very high chance you will
be killed and that's totally unnatural
and a novel evolutionary experience i
think
then there's sexual coercion within
groups
and um
so that takes various kinds of forms
you know but nowadays of course i think
people recognize increasingly that
the principal form of
sexual intimidation
and rape
occurs within relationships
it's not stranger rape that is really
you know statistically uh important
there's much more
um what happens uh
behind the walls
of uh
a bedroom where people have been living
for some time
and
um
just two sort of you know thoughts and
observations about this uh one is that
it may seem odd
that
um
that males should be
i
should think it you know a good idea as
it were to
uh impose themselves sexually on someone
with whom they have a relationship
but what they're doing is uh
intimidating someone uh in a
relationship in which
the relative power in the relationship
has continuing significance uh for a
long time
and that power probably goes well beyond
uh just the sexual you know it's it's to
do with domestic relationships is to do
with
the man getting his his own way al all
the way it's power dynamics and uh the
sexual aggression is one of the tools to
regain power gain power gain more power
and that kind of thing yeah
exactly and and in that respect
um
it's worth noting that
although this wasn't appreciated uh for
some time it's it's emerging that in a
bunch of primates you have somewhat
similar or
somewhat parallel kinds of
sexual intimidation
where males will target particular
females even in a
group in which the norm is for females
to mate with multiple males
but each male will target a particular
female and um the more he is aggressive
towards her then the more she
conforms to his wishes when he wants to
mate
so a long-term pattern of sexual
intimidation
so there's that aspect the other aspect
i would just just note is that
males get away with a lot compared to
females in the any kind of intersexual
conflict
um
you know so the punishment uh
here's one example of this the
punishment for a husband killing a wife
has always been much less than the
punishment for a wife killing a husband
and and you see similar sorts of things
in terms of the punishments for adultery
and
and so on and
i bring this up in the context of
of males
sexually intimidating uh their partners
be be
or whoever
because it's a reminder that
it's basically a patriarchal world that
we have come from
a patriarchal world in which
male alliances
tend to support males
and take advantage of the fact that they
have political power at the expense of
females
and i would say that that all goes back
to what happened three to four hundred
thousand years ago
when the beta males took charge and they
started imposing their own norms on
society as a whole and they've continued
to do so and you we now look at
ourselves and you know jordan peterson
says we are not a patriarchal society
well you know it's true that the laws
try and make it even-handed nowadays
between males and females but obviously
we are patriarchal de facto
because society still in many ways
supports
men better than it supports women in
these sorts of conflicts
you